pas mal non c'est la première rencontre
de guy laliberté avec les médias depuis
la vente du cirque du soleil en 2015
il voulait présenter ses nouveaux
projets de laboratoire créatif ce qu'on
ne ferait qu'une rouge c'est une mettant
en place les outils - environnement
tu va permettre aux jeunes entrepreneurs
pour aux jeunes créateurs doivent
pouvoir fit et de cette fenêtre losc
semble croiser le fil a été rattrapé par
les projets du cirque du soleil en
arabie saoudite
il dit avoir des réticences sur
certaines décisions à wissant quelque
chose mais c'est pas moi je dessine je
fais pas pu se procurer huit mamans qui
crise qui les lieux anisé dit ok mais je
mets valait ramoin puis nécessairement
nous on a fait des choix de nos jeux par
les deux ont exploré
ils ont été approchés pour le moment
donné c'est clair que c'est pas
nécessairement environnement
présentement qui lequel devrait entourer
jusque dans le contexte actuel de ses
doigts aussi avant son malaise bienvenue
à bord de la station spatiale
internationale
autre sujet de controverse ses déboires
avec l' agence du revenu du canada à qui
il doit plusieurs millions de dollars à
la suite de son voyage dans l'espace
vraiment pose question c'est une
possibilité d'appel ces ténèbres
vraiment une pause casse et au lycée
d'assevent truc c'est bon on arrive par
voie de communiqué comme vous voyez on a
pris la décision de s'installer dans ce
lieu qui s'appelle la main
en attendant guy laliberté prépare son
nouveau projet lune rouge dans ses
nouveaux locaux au centre-ville de
montréal
l'entrepreneur veut aménager des
laboratoires de création de réalité
virtuelle et d'intelligence artificielle
de jeux vidéo et cinéma
il promet de dévoiler deux projets qui
sont nés avec l'une rouge dans la
semaine du 5 novembre
ici à nombre d'anneaux radio canada
montréal